Speaker 1: David, is it likely that if Trump
runs in 2004, he will be unopposed in the
Republican primary?
No, Trump, if he runs in twenty four, Trump
will almost certainly be opposed.
The question is whether it will be a serious
challenger.
We could if we were to imagine what is the
most serious challenge that Donald Trump could
face.
One school of thought would be somebody like
Mitt Romney runs an anti Trump Republican
with some name recognition.
I don't know that Romney gets more than 10
or maybe 15 percent in a Republican primary.
I think the way things are right now, Trump
owns the Republican Party.
Trump crushes basically whoever tries to run
against him.
The one name that seems to have more power
against Trump would be Ron DeSantis, who is
essentially a more competent Trump, which
is extraordinarily dangerous even to seems
to have only low 20s.
I think in a couple of recent straw polls,
it was something like twenty one twenty two
percent support or something like that.
So at this point in time, this nomination
is Trump's for the taking.
If he wants it, if he wants it, I don't think
anybody else is going to be able to mount
a successful challenge.
You know, people talk about what about Lisa
Murkowski or something?
No, I just don't see it.
I just don't see the name recognition.
I just don't see the interest level, so to
speak, in supporting her over Trump when Trump
is sort of the de facto and as of as of today,
still widely supported by the Republican Party.
I think that Trump's perspective on this let
me go back.
When I was on Michael Cohen's podcast a couple
of weeks ago, Michael Cohen said he doesn't
think ultimately that Donald Trump runs.
And he had a number of different reasons that
he gave.
We uploaded that to our YouTube channel.
And you can check that out if you want to
hear more about that.
But one of the arguments about why Trump ultimately
won't run is Trump is able to raise money
and benefit from kind of alluding to running
and doing events and asking people to donate
to the Save America PAC or whatever, but not
actually saying I'm running and maybe never
actually running.
The idea being raised as much money as he
can get as much attention as possible, paralyze
the party so the party can't say, OK, he's
not running, but they also can't say he is
running.
As for as long as Trump is doing speeches
and talking about I think you'll like what
we decide, but not announcing a candidacy,
he paralyzes the Republican Party.
He keeps people under his thumb.
And that's exactly what Donald Trump wants
to do.
And he can just keep grifting his supporters.
New report he raised, who knows, tens of millions
of dollars over the last six months, claiming
it's all to fight the election results.
He has spent no money on fighting the election
results because the election was nine months
ago and nothing is going to change.
But that's what Trump wants to do.
He wants to keep raising money.
So I also see that even if Trump is not ultimately
going to run, it's very much to his advantage
to pretend that he is.
My instinct is if he's healthy and twenty
twenty two goes OK for the Trump wing of the
party Trump runs, that's my opinion.
Only Michael Cohen said I think he he doesn't
run.
In the end, an ego is a factor.
And a few other things we will just have to
wait and see.
But the best case scenario for Trump would
be that this, if he is ultimately going to
run, that keeping this situation in limbo
prevents the Republican Party from really
getting behind anybody else in particular,
it prevents other people from really building
support because Trump still has the majority
of the electorate supporting him.
And then he says, I'm running if that's indeed
what he's going to do and he doesn't even
give oxygen to a possible serious primary
challenge.
The other thing would be, what if Trump runs
third party?
I don't even really want to get into that
right now because I see it as very, very unlikely.
But if you're if the scenario you think is
the most likely as Trump runs third party,
I would love to hear
from you.